this week millions of americans
experienced a thanksgiving like no other
with heightened restrictions put in
place
by governors across the country in
response to spikes
in coronavirus cases joining me now from
little rock is arkansas governor asa
hutchinson vice chair of the national
governors
association governor welcome to fox news
sunday
thank you brad it is good to be with you
today
you know arkansas has been dealing with
this and
where do you think your state is just in
hospitalizations
as of last week friday it surpassed one
thousand
for the first time in your state uh
tough number where are you
well the hospitalizations is the great
concern
and that is a record number of coveted
patients that we've had hospitalized it
hopefully will stabilize
we have a hospital group that's working
with me very closely
to make sure that we continue to have
adequate hospital space
for both covid patients which is really
a
minority of those that are in the
hospital as well as caring for all the
other health
care needs that we have during the last
three weeks since we've had this most
recent spike the people of arkansas are
taking this
extraordinarily seriously i think we had
a very subdued
thanksgiving we're very thankful but at
the same time
people understand the risk of large
gatherings
and the importance of social distancing
we're trying to take the approach
that we want to make sure that our
guidelines are followed we
we've increased our enforcement efforts
we've
worked with our hospitals to make sure
that we have space there
we're not trying to shut down businesses
that are doing a good job
we still have some limitations in
spacing in our restaurants
and gyms those are important to be
enforced
but we realize that you can really
increase
problems across the board if you start
shutting down businesses putting people
unemployed as we go into the christmas
season
you mentioned enforcement you have a
statewide mass mandate
you've had some doctors write you a
letter saying they would really like you
to enforce
that it states that it could result in a
five hundred dollar
fine are you doing that on the mass
mandate date front
well in terms of our restaurants our
regulated industries we have inspections
we're enforcing the mask mandate the
spacing requirements as well
in terms of the general population
we have to rely upon our local law
enforcement
and that's a gap because there's a lot
of hesitancy about going out and
arresting someone for not
having a mask on and so you know there's
a warning that's given we're working
with our municipal officials to
increase that education part of it and
the compliance efforts on the mask
everybody knows what needs to be done
and we have that mass mandate in
arkansas
vast majority are following that we've
put in
millions of dollars into an ad campaign
stressing the science behind
the reason we need to do that i think
that's the right approach but we're
always looking for more ways to
strengthen that
compliance and make it better on the
flip side you have made clear
and you just did that there will be no
shutdown of businesses again
well i don't know if you ever say never
but that's the last thing that we want
to do and particularly
shutting down a business that has worked
hard for the last eight months to comply
with every public health directive
and they have safe
positions within their restaurant and
they have no cases coming out of it
and so that to me is just fundamentally
wrong to say you're out of business now
uh and your workers are unemployed
particularly whenever
there's not any karex relief package
anymore
that money has been allocated we've
tried to help our small businesses
but we're not able to compensate someone
for
their loss of a job for their loss of an
income and shutting down a business
so we want to be smart about it and so
we did put 11 p.m curfew on bars and
restaurants trying to
break up the late night crowds but at
the same time
we don't want to overly restrict our
businesses that are doing a good job out
there
because that just makes the problem
worse
should arkansas students be back in
school physically as opposed to
virtually
you know i tell you a story of i just
know of a couple that are both working
and the school had to go virtual
and so what do you do with the children
when both parents are working
they had them stay over at a friend's
house and the child
was positive within days because of the
friend
and so the important thing is that the
school is a safe environment
we have the option to go virtual and to
pivot there
based upon local decisions in local
cases but to say carte blanche we're
going to close our schools we're not
going to have the in classroom
instruction as an option
would really have some adverse
consequences that we don't need and
are not necessary and so we want to be
able to keep those open
with the option to pivot to virtual
based upon local
circumstances but we want to minimize
that effort when we can
going to school is very important on the
higher education side
you know as our students come back we
want them to get tested
we want them to if they've been in a hot
zone or they've been
among people or not protected to make
sure they isolate or they get tested as
they come back
i want to turn for a minute to the
election president trump governor as you
know has not conceded the election he
continues to say
that it was stolen computer experts
within his own administration have
pushed back on that
take a listen there has been so much
fraud that we have uncovered
as a campaign and listen people need to
know going forward it's not just about
right now
we need to know that every election we
hold in the united states of america
is fair and legal and every legitimate
vote gets counted
was the most secure in american history
there is no evidence
that any voting system deleted or lost
votes or changed votes or was in any way
compromised yeah i stand by that the
american people should have
100 percent confidence in their vote
so governor have you seen anything that
suggests
that there is evidence that the
president could prevail in overturning
the election that has already been
certified
in a number of key states uh most
importantly the courts have not seen any
evidence
of such extensive fraud that they have
to change a result
scores of courts have looked at that and
so
that's why the general service
administration recognized
vice president biden as president-elect
he is president-elect
we need to work in that transition i
applaud president trump for
initiating that transition and making
sure that that is happening
the worst thing that could happen is
that
we do not have a smooth handoff when it
comes to our vaccine distribution
plans our warp speed and that takes uh
that transition to start now and i'm
grateful that it has
but i do think whenever you look at the
elections it would be good
after the fact that we have a bipartisan
review as to what's best practices
because this is going to come up again
as to how to handle
absentee votes what's the best way to
protect the integrity of those votes
to give people confidence and that's not
to say everything was
was fraudulent on this election it just
says that we need to learn from each
other
all the 50 states and to what we have
done and how we can do it better and to
give people confidence
that is so important in our democracy
so you think the president should
officially concede
well i i i understand the legal reason
why
should not because he has some appeals
that are going so i recognize that
but beyond that uh it's president-elect
uh biden uh we're working with the
transition
that is where we are we expect him to be
sworn in in january
even though there's going to be some
continued reviews which i respect
and it's not that important uh the the
transition is what is important
the words of president trump are not
quite as significant
but the actions are important in helping
in this transition
to make sure that president-elect biden
is ready to go
uh on january 20th governor hutchinson
we appreciate your time thank you